[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et un plaisir de vous
retrouver comme chaque soir d'un point
de vue chaque soir à la même heure avec
deux invités mais qui sont chaque soir
différents bonsoir à shelby nasa
vous êtes journaliste vous collaborez en
particulier aux magazines l'express et à
marianne vous oubliez d'ailleurs cet
après midi sur le site de marianne
article consacré à la laïcité au québec
et bonsoir richard boyer bonsoir vous
êtes première adjointe socialiste de la
maire du 12e arrondissement de paris les
également l'un des experts de la
fondation jean jaurès dont nous allons
reparler dans quelques minutes à travers
un de ses rapports mais on va commencer
si vous le voulez bien par revenir sur
ce dialogue intéressant et instructif
entre le président de la république
emmanuel macron et une habitante de
montpellier c'était avant-hier et
cette dame madame naïma amadou expliqué
aux présents à public que la diversité
ou la mixité s'était terminée en tout
cas dans l'école de ses enfants dans le
collège du quartier les gens ne mettent
plus les enfants dans le même quartier
et ce qui est vraiment dommage
monsieur le président j'ai mon fils qui
habite ans il m'a demandé si les prénoms
de pierre existait vraiment c'est que
dans le livre
tellement qu'ils aiment manque de mixité
dans le quartier c'est vraiment grave
quoi je lui ai dit non au fils pierre
existe vraiment il ya des gens qui
s'appellent pierre richard vague est ce
que vous êtes surpris par ce type de
dialogue
sachant je le disais que vous avez une
responsabilité d'élu local dans le 2e
arrondissement de paris où il ya aussi
des populations sûrement issus de
l'immigration
est ce que vous vous vivez la même chose
que cette dame ou est ce contrat il se
passe les mêmes types de situation dans
votre arrondissement probablement pas de
la manière dont s'est exprimée par la
personne auprès du président de la
république néanmoins la question de la
mixité
d'une manière générale de la mixité
sociale parce qu'il ya d'autres types de
mixité on pourrait parler garçons filles
on pourrait parler de mixité scolaire
on y reviendra peut-être il ya aussi le
problème de mixité sociale et là je
pense qu'elle parlait cette femme à la
fin de mixité scolaire et de mixité
sociale où pourtant clairement elle
parlé d'humilité et nikos livre à ce que
sans elle dit les enfants salle pierre
aussi il ya les trois niveaux ne sont
pas ne sont pas exclusifs l'un de
l'autre puisque on a les trois strates
je crois dans ce qu'elle évoque en 2015
je crois le cne sco est donc le centre
national d'étude du système scolaire en
france sous l'égide de nathalie mons
avait fait une étude qui montrait
combien tous les phénomènes à la fois d'
absence de mixité et de ségrégation
était très forte en france au niveau des
collèges et elle ciblait une centaine
d'établissements en france où
particulièrement et l'aspect de
d'absence de mixité sociale et d'absence
de mixité scolaire était très prégnante
et comment on pouvait envisager d'y
remédier ça nécessite bien évidemment
des volontés politiques ne sont pas
toujours au rendez vous
ça nécessite aussi de ne pas faire de la
mixité un objectif en soi mais bien un
moyen c'est-à-dire que la mixité est un
moyen pour construire des choses elle
n'est pas l'objectif forcément à
atteindre en soit c'est dire que dans
certains endroits la mixité
elle est de fait il n'y a pas forcément
besoin d'avoir des mesures qui sont pas
contraignantes on a dans les écoles on a
dans les établissements scolaires des
mixités dans à la fois les populations
qui sont là dans la répartition des
classes et puis on a dans certains
territoires cette mixité qui n'est plus
présente
elle est à la fois une absence de mixité
résidentiel qu'il faut prendre en compte
des études en belgique ont montré que la
mixité résidentiel ne répondait pas
exactement à la mixité scolaire parce
qu'il y avait aussi des choix et des
stratégies à la fois d'évitement de
reclassement qui était un petit peu
particulière donc là on est sur un
phénomène qui est à la fois intéressant
pourquoi parce que toutes les études
nous montrent que la mixité à l'école
est plutôt intéressante notamment pour
les élèves qui sont j'allais dire les
plus avec des difficultés scolaires on
apprend mieux quand on est mélangé avec
des élèves qui marche bien à l'école et
en même temps quand on interroge les
parents les parents ils ont aussi envie
du meilleur pour leurs enfants et
parfois ils n'ont pas envie que leurs
enfants même bon à l'école se retrouve
dans une classe avec des moins bons des
parents plutôt envie de mettre tous les
atouts de leur côté pour que leurs
enfants réussissent et donc
donc on est sur une espèce de
contradiction qu'il faut qu'il faut
prendre en compte mais c'est à dire
entre une demande qui est celle des
parents et même si on peut affirmer que
la mixité finalement à l'école ne fait
pas perdre beaucoup au très bon et c'est
plutôt beaucoup gagné au moins bon c'est
des études du klitschko 2015 encore une
fois fait part des chercheurs avec des
statistiques
néanmoins pour les parents ce discours
là ne passe pas peut-être
aussi que les parents branchés menaces
n'ont pas envie de voir leurs enfants
dans des environnements disons les
choses clairement parce qu'un point de
vue on aime pas du bois qui sont trop
communautariser moi je si j'avais été le
président de la république et avec tout
le respect que les délicatesses
nécessaire j'aurais peut-être répondu à
cette dame est réfléchie c'est peut-être
que le fait que vous portez votre voile
islamique est une façon de revendiquer
votre différence ça n'incite pas les
autres familles à mettre leurs enfants
dans la même école que le vôtre on feint
de s'étonner de ce qu'en fait on connaît
depuis déjà très longtemps
en effet cette mère de famille n'a pas
appelé son enfant pierre
donc il est facile de dénoncer un manque
de mixité mais il est aussi nécessaire
de s'interroger justement sur ces
opérations peut-être manque
d'intégration d'assimilation selon le
mot qu'on préfère en fait quand on parle
ici du prénom pierre c'est la question
culturelle qui s'expriment très
clairement pendant des années avec une
forme de pudeur
on s'est concentré sur ce qu'on a appelé
la mixité la mixité sociale
alors qu'en réalité ce dont on voulait
parler c'est de la mixité culturelle
culturelle ou ethnique comme on veut ou
religieuses mais très souvent en fait le
religieux est mêlé avec le culturel
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
s'impose qui s'exprime et en effet ces
demandes et pas forcément par des
individus des personnes qui sont des
français de confession catholique mais
même par des parents d'élèves qui sont
de confession musulmane
le succès des écoles des écoles privées
il est pas due seulement aux pierres au
paul même des petits samir ou des nadia
sont scolarisés dans des établissements
dans des établissements privés et ça
signifie quelque chose donc cesser une
fois de plus l'illustration de dans
certains des nids dans tabou dans la
société c'est à dire celui de se
concentrer sur la mixité ce qu'on a
appelé la mixité sociale mais qui en
réalité et de la mixité culturelle et ou
ethnique
ja
un grand socialiste s'appelait françois
mitterrand qui avait évoqué l'expression
du seuil de tolérance
écoutez la réaction de gérald darmanin à
cet échange avec le président de la
république entre le président de la
république et ces dames
il ne dit pas qu'il ya peut-être une
responsabilité d'une immigration
excessive mais il est quand même peu
contrôlées et ça c'est intéressant
bon il s'est passé 40 ans de politique
d'urbanisme et de logement
un peu délirante il s'est passé aussi
une immigration parfois peut contrôler
et puis c'est passé aussi le manque de
volonté générale de faire de la mixité
sociale
et ça vaut qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi un
phénomène que on va dire de nombre qui
fait qu'on ne peut plus avoir la mixité
parce que dans certains quartiers il ya
une majorité de populations musulmanes
pour dire les choses que façon
directement une population musulmane
française de religion musulmane pas
exactement bien sûr population musulmane
c'est pas une population musulmane spain
nationalité et on n'a pas de
statistiques de nationalité musulmane
mais ça marche en bosnie mais ça marche
pas en france le musulmane en
l'occurrence je pense que c'est une
approche
mais attention à ce qu'on a ce qu'on dit
d'abord ce phénomène là il n'est pas
vrai partout en france on connaît une
même région en france guillaume roquette
franchement quand vous allez dans les
établissements à rodez dans les
établissements à saint geniès dole dans
des établissements à millau la question
de la mixité
elle ne se pose pas de la même manière
que dans bach dernier segment de
l'aveyron pour absolument rare donc
forcément que l'avion n'est pas
exactement le département représentatif
exactement lui migratoire enfants
exactement ils savent comme alors mais
tout à fait mais ça veut bien dire que
cette question de la mixité
elle se concentre particulièrement dans
certains quartiers et c'est ce que
montrent les années les statistiques
c'est dans certains quartiers qu'on l'a
ce type de questions qui se posent et
dans ces quartiers là on a une
cumulation de problème on a un problème
qui est d'ordre social
on imprime qui est d'ordre résidentiel
et qui dort aussi d'arriver de flux
migratoires qui à un moment donné ont vu
se concentrer dans certains dans
certaines villes dont certaines dans
certains territoires
les logements sociaux dans lesquels sont
accueillis en grande majorité des
personnes qui viennent aussi de horizons
différents qui ne sont pas de
naturalisation française et qui viennent
avec
premier parcours migratoire et on a dans
certains territoires l'ensemble de ces
situations qu'il faut être qu'il faut
régler mes mangas je pense que la
question des logements de sociaux de
côté
on le sait le nombre de villes alors
certes ça ne concerne pas toute la
france mais ça concerne de plus en plus
de villes et même dans des quartiers où
il n'y a pas forcément des logements
sociaux il ya des problématiques qui se
posent aujourd'hui on sait que dans un
nombre croissant d'établissements
quand vous avez par exemple un enfant
qui est juif ou d'origine juive que ce
soit réelle ou supposée
on ne peut pas le scolarisés dans un
établissement public et le nombre
d'établissements et trois en partie non
c'est pas vrai partout et de plus en
plus dans les cei devrait changer
l'école publique sauf que c'est de plus
en plus rares parce que de plus en plus
d'établissements dans lequel c'est
exactement l'inversé la dynamique c'est
pas celle justement d'une baisse c'est
celle d'une bosse et force est de
constater que en fait ça ça n'existe pas
depuis cinq ans ou dix ans ça existe
depuis près de vingt ans et on le sait
aujourd'hui le nombre d'établissements
il est croissant je vous livre les
réflexions de nos internautes vous êtes
60 2% a considéré que l'absence de
mixité à l'école est elle même
l'échec d'une absence est elle-même
pardon le reflet de l'échec de la mixité
dans la société française voici quelques
réactions celle de nathan 770 sur
lefigaro.fr
je ne peux pas mettre mes enfants dans
une école publique je ne le peut plus
écrit-il avec plus en majuscules il se
ferait tabasser l'école n'est pas faute
il noue des françoises bianchi charles
youtube
elle joue toujours le rôle d'ascenseur
social pour les jeunes et les familles
qui le souhaitent
l'obstacle n'est pas à l'école il est
dans les quartiers et dans la pression
du groupe autour des familles pour
qu'elles ne s'intègrent pas
et puis cette réflexion de nicole 06 le
problème c'est qu'une grande majorité de
français ne veut pas de cette mixité là
est ce que richard bouygues là l'absence
de d'exigence de la société française ne
serait ce que de l'emploi du mot
assimilation peut être l'un des facteurs
d'explication est ce que si par exemple
on avait gardé la loi ancienne sur les
prénoms
vous savez où il fallait donner à ces
enfants des prénoms du calendrier des
calendriers est ce que ce genre de
choses dans votre avis ça peut jouer
c'est dire qu'à une forme de repli
identitaire
moi je ne me sens pas du tout aller sur
ce terrain là comme étant le terrain de
l'explication je ne pense pas est-ce
qu'il faut parler d'intégration ou
d'assimilation
je ne sais pas je crois que patrick weil
qui est pourtant réputé pour être un
chercheur plutôt très marqué à gauche
n'a pas du tout de réticences à employer
le mot d'assimilation quand d'autres par
contre ont cette réticence parce que ce
mot a été parfois utilisé est récupéré
par l'extrême droite avec à l'intérieur
dans l'assimilation un contenu qui n'est
pas exactement le même que patrick weil
et dans l'accès à la citoyenneté on n'y
met pas la même chose quand on est
patrick weil ou quand on est à l'extrême
droite est donc ce mot peut être a pu
rebuter moi je pense qu'il faut se
mettre d'accord sur le contenu de ce
qu'on veut en termes d'intégration et
bien évidemment que depuis des années
des années des décennies la partie
intégration a été une partie ratée en
france d'abord parce qu'on ne s'est pas
donné les moyens parce qu'on n'a pas mis
le diagnostic et qu'on n'a pas posé les
éléments dessus donc oui on nous avons
raté la partie des politiques
d'intégration et de l'intégration d'une
partie de la société d'une part parce
qu'on ne s'est pas donné les moyens et
d'autre part parce qu'on a laissé filer
des choses parce qu'on a abandonné des
choses parce qu'on a considéré qu' il
n'était pas bien d'intervenir sur
certains phénomènes sur salat quoi par
exemple mais je pense que le phénomène
de communautarisation je pense que le
communautarisme d'une manière générale
je pense que la manière dont à un moment
donné s'organise la vie dans des
quartiers que toutes ces questions là on
était un peu mise de côté je pense qu'on
a un clientélisme
oui exactement mais même qu un
clientélisme électoral mais très à
l'aise pour dire que ça va aussi avec ça
je ne
mettons tout sur la table il ya un échec
global chacun ya sa part les politiques
qui ont leur part les associatifs y ont
leur part les parents et ont leur part
et puis la société en général aussi à
leur part parce qu'elles véhiculent
aussi parfois des clichés qui sont des
clichés difficiles qui peuvent être
valables pour certains et pas pour
d'autres et qu'à un moment donné le fait
qu'on pour le coup assimile tout le
monde derrière le cliché ne favorise pas
non plus les bons parcours à la fois
d'intégration les bons parcours de
réussite on a aussi des talents dans les
quartiers on a aussi des gens qui ont
des choses à raconter sur leur parcours
et cela par contre sont un peu éteint
aussi par pas par leur est donc je pense
qu'on a réellement rater cette politique
après la politique de l'intégration
je pense que le mot n'est pas c'est le
plus tôt le contenu et je pense qu'on a
raté quelque chose oui vous pensez qu'il
est encore temps de rattraper cette
situation à chablis nasse où il est bien
tard bon en matière de de mixité à
l'école il faut pas céder au désespoir
mais ce serait un péché qui commente la
vie de la cité gély
mais ce qui est certain c'est sur du
court et moyen terme
force est de constater que c'est très
compliqué pour ne pas dire impossible
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ça doit
qu'on doit se faire l'économie justement
de mesures mais ces mesures ne verront
leurs effets appliqués que sur du long
terme en réalité sur du court et moyen
terme
richard rainbow il est bien dit le
retard et elle les acteurs à mobiliser
les familles c'est très difficile quand
il s'agit pour l'école de faire
concurrence avec le discours qui est
entendu dans les familles le premier
acteur c'est celui ci donc c'est
extrêmement complexe et à cela s'ajoute
la question l'épineuse question du
nombre c'est à dire que l'intégration
l'assimilation comme on veut elle et
elle peut être violente quand vous
arrive dans un pays et qu'il s'agit
d'épouser une partie de sa culture ça
peut être violent quand vous arrivez
dans un quartier et dans une région dans
une ville où de toute façon vous êtes
majoritaires
pourquoi vous allez faire l'effort
justement pourquoi vous allait céder à
cette espèce de violence pour vous
assimiler à une culture qui n'est pas la
vôtre ça marche pour tout le monde ça
marche pour les français quand des
français partent à l'étranger
et se retrouve dans des environnements
où ils sont majoritaires ils ne feront
pas l'effort d'épouser la culture
d'accueil donc donc en effet il ya aussi
cette problématique là qu'il faut pas
totalement aux maîtres si on veut
vraiment régler la question
deux dernières réactions si vous le
voulez bien de nos internautes qui sont
assez proches d'ailleurs l'une de
l'autre celle d'axel sur lefigaro.fr le
diagnostic c'est qu'on ne peut pas
intégrer en grand nombre des
communautaristes et puis quelques propos
aussi sur le risque de séparatisme c'est
général escape c'est évidemment pseudo
sur youtube qui le dit ce n'est pas
l'école qui traduit l'échec de la mixité
mais bien la mixité en elle-même qui est
en échec donc le séparatisme et dans les
quartiers et dans les pensées avant
d'être dans l'école même si heureusement
ce n'est pas le cas partout
un autre sujet qui est peut-être
connexes aux précédents il existe une
possibilité non négligeable que marine
le pen remporte la prochaine élection
présidentielle ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est la fondation jean jaurès ou
plus précisément un de ces rapports qui
a été publié aujourd'hui un rapport
passionnant qui d'ailleurs
téléchargeable sur le site de ce think
tank de sensibilité sociale démocrate on
va dire un richard briques bouquillon
d'être un des piliers c'est la
définition
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on dit
alors pour faire court parce que ça fait
22 pages de la fondation jean jaurès
relève qu' il ya des points d'accords
importants peut-être croissant entre
l'électorat des républicains et
l'électorat du rassemblement national en
particulier sur les sujets de société
qui fait qu' un certain nombre de ses
électeurs pourraient voter pour marine
le pen qui faisait pas jusqu'à présent
le deuxième point c'est la
dédiabolisation c'est dire que marine le
pen fait moins peur et le dernier point
c'est le rejet personnel dont peut faire
l'objet
emmanuel macron qui inciterait un
certain nombre d'électeurs de gauche en
particulier à la gauche de la gauche à
ne pas voter pour lui et donc à ne pas à
reconstituer ce qu'on appelle
d'ordinaire le front républicain c'est à
dire une alliance de tous les partis
contre le rassemblement national
raffinage est ce que vous trouvez que ce
constat il est
spécialement pertinent aujourd'hui où
est ce que ce risque-là il existe comme
il existait en 2017 c'est difficile
parce que cette possibilité d'ailleurs
disons que le tabou du nom de famille
existe encore et à cela on doit ajouter
le soupçon d' incompétence que marine le
pen porte encore qu'elle est qu'elle
n'est pas arrivé à se débarrasser depuis
le fameux débat de la présidentielle
s'il voulait elle ne porte pas
l'héritage culturel rhétorique de sa
famille ce qui peut la servir comme la
desservir en réalité il ya des avantages
à également des inconvénients
vous pensez avoir imploré aux réflexions
antisémite de jean marie le pen connaît
un peu neuneu n'a jamais repris à son
compte marine n'est pas exactement on ne
peut pas la soupçonner de fascisme nous
enfin à moins d'être d'être de mauvaise
foi
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
au sein de son propre parti
elle ne fait pas non plus l'unanimité
basquiat pas ce côté ce cet héritage
intellectuel culturel se soucie de la
langue des formules qui avait notamment
avec un carnet qu'incarner son père la
difficulté pour elle ça va être en fait
surtout de rassembler certes elle a
amorcé un virage très intéressant même
si on est un petit peu sous-estimé avec
la stratégie philippe un virage social
aujourd'hui elle incarne une droite
populaire qui peut à bien des égards
semblait orpheline elle elle incarne ça
mais de là à rassembler autour d'elle
parce que c'est un impératif si elle
veut faire un score suffisant il va
falloir rassembler donc c'est à dire pas
rassembler des individus tels que
mariani mais rassembler des courants des
courants de droite
des blocs élitiste ce qui n'est pas du
tout aujourd'hui aujourd'hui son cas
sans ça il ya fort à parier que le
plafond de verre continuera de persister
et aura raison de son score final voilà
faisions un mariani à thierry mariani
ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
les républicains après l'ump à l'époque
passé d'épuration nationale dont il est
député européen et je comptais de liste
pour les élections régionales en paca
richard brigue si si on entre un peu
dans le détail de cette étude il ya
l'idée que les électeurs de la droite
classique sont de plus en plus séduits
par les les idées de marine le pen est
ce que ça vous paraît à un diagnostic
pertinent
oui le diagnostic est pertinent parce qu
ils l'évoquent deux points concomitants
d'abord le fait qu'il y ait de plus en
plus d'affinités sur les problématiques
sociétales et culturelles entre ces deux
électorats alors que très longtemps il y
a eu une barrière qui était celle
notamment des questions économiques qui
ont fait que ces deux électorats n'était
pas en gros compatible à un moment donné
maintenant vous voulez sortir de l'euro
exactement dont la vue à la dernière
élection présidentielle c'est que le
programme économique de marine le pen a
été véritablement son talon d'achille
et il a notamment du côté de l'électorat
de droite était quelque chose qui a été
un repoussoir vraiment un repoussoir
elle a depuis changé les personnes avec
lesquelles elle travaille sur son
programme économique qui a eu beaucoup
d'eau dans son vin
par rapport à cette sortie de l'euro et
de l'europe
bref elle reste avec des marqueurs mais
on sent que le discours d'abord se fait
un peu moins présent dans les médias et
d'autre part qu'elle a un peu plus
atténuée il reste que sur les questions
qui sont celles des clivages sociétaux
d'équilibriste coûtera lilly a entre les
deux électorats les enquêtes le montrent
régulièrement des points de convergence
et c'est vrai à la fois parmi les élus
des partis mais c'est vrai aussi pour
les électeurs qui sont les électeurs à
la base de ces deux de ces deux partis
donc oui ce n'est pas ni fantasmer ni
exagérer que de dire qu'il ya des points
de convergence entre les deux et que
c'est par là une des possibilités pour
marine le pen puisque vous avez cité les
trois options qui sont celles qui ferait
que marine le pen pourrait à un moment
donné à voir un surplus dans dans les
urnes qui est dans le premier c'est
comment elle réussi à grignoter une
partie de l'électorat des républicains
pas celui qui a été déjà pris par
emmanuel macron de quelques temps mais
celui qui reste et qui l' a beaucoup
plus d'adhésions et d'adhérence avec le
discours du front national donc oui je
pense que c'est pas quelque chose de
complètement idiot et en l'occurrence on
n'est plus du tout à l'époque dé michel
noir on n'est plus du tout à l'époque
même du discours de jacques chirac
rappelons-nous
et du cordon sanitaire on a complètement
basculé à droite là je vous le renvoi
mais vous avez le discours a basculé à
droite par rapport au front national le
cordon sanitaire avec jacques chirac est
aujourd'hui c'est le discours de gérald
darmanin qui a fait parler de lui lors
d'une émission télévisée où en gros
c'était un peu autre chose donc on sent
qu'il ya quelque chose et ça va alors
j'ai fini parce que dans les trois
points que vous avez évoquées même sont
complètement juste mais il ya un point
quand même et je le dis à moi aussi
l'analyse électorale c'est que la france
est très à droite et en fait je pense
que c'est le quatrième point séjour
était le cas alors de pas avec des
proportions avec des proportions
vraiment très différentes là le total
gauche
au total gauche les 25 tonnes à droite
les 40 pour faire court voilà mais je
veux dire le total gauche à 25
c'est aussi une tendance qui marque un
basculement des lectorats droite qui
fait que à un deuxième tour où vous avez
marine le pen et emmanuel macron 6e
cette photo se réalise on est on est
encore loin loin du but mais si cette
photo se réalise si l'ue n'arrive à dire
qu'elle incarne la droite et que l'autre
n'arrive pas à dire qu'il incarne une
partie de la droite
alors il ya un rabattage des cartes et
là c'est quelque chose qui peut
interroger
on a réellement une carte électorale
dans les sondages qui est vraiment très
atrophiée agos donc et qui laisse donc
des options pour marine le pen parce que
ceux qui font le plus pour le en gros
front républicain où le barrage
républicain même si il s'est effritée
depuis mais c'est quand même la gauche
qui joue ce rôle là mais puisque elle
diminue d'autant
elle laisse aussi mécaniquement d'autres
espaces pour d'autres compositions
vous parlez de jacques chirac est
d'ailleurs cette étude 2 reprend des
passages du discours sous le nom de
jacques chirac après le premier tour le
21 avril d'ailleurs c'était il ya tout
juste et même d après de nicolas sarkozy
sur le fait qu'elle est dans le champ
républicain enfin il ya une bonne
analyse seulement la manière dont va
évoluer le discours mais qui là encore
une fois c'est ses sens en parler de
jugement mais il ya une évolution forte
du discours qui est probablement aussi
une évolution forte la carte électorale
et du et de l'électorat l'uimm c'est
vrai
moi qui suis sur le plus âgé d'entre
nous trois ici je peux vous dire que si
on remonte encore plus loin
à la fin des années 80 ce qui était le
programme notamment sur l'immigration de
toute la droite c'est dire qu'ils
avaient une déclaration commune qu'ils
allaient de françois bayrou alain juppé
en passant par jacques chirac et les
autres leaders de la droite c'était
suspension du regroupement familial
enfin il ya eu peut-être un mouvement de
balancier aussi peut-être que la droite
classique est allé vers le centre avec
jacques chirac que du coup il ya une
partie de l'électorat qui est parti fin
selon qu'on remonte loin ou très loin on
peut dire c'est la droite qui court
derrière l'assemblée nationale où c'est
le rassemblement national qui s'est
substituée à la droite sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais ça ne s'est pas un
conte page
non mesdames est absolument bien au
contraire c'est juste une mise en
perspective je vous donne les
commentaires de nos internautes qui sont
assez nombreux
fouteret mécontenter personne on va
commencer par les chiffres
marine le pen peut-elle selon vous
devenir présidente de la république en
c'est non à 50 2% effectivement c'est
une majorité qui est peut-être 53 dans
le pied et voilà exactement certains le
sondage font état de 53 ans n'est pas
loin oui absolument pour un second tour
où marine le pen se retrouverait face à
emmanuel mâcon où donc ce dernier ne
l'emporterait que de justesse entre
guillemets qu'est ce qu'il y a comme
parmi les commentaires dommage que
l'esprit des futurs électeurs soit déjà
greffé est anéantie par le duel macron
le pen ou d'une autre sur le figaro.fr
nicole 0,6 si on est dans ce cas de face
à face au second tour je préfèrerais
vote et rn plutôt que macron cinq ans
suffisent
si la campagne s'oriente sur des
questions sécuritaires nous dit draco
fit tv sur youtube
marie népal a des chances de l'emporter
surtout qu emmanuel macron n'est pas
crédible sur ce sujet oui même si il a
quand même pris une offensive clair sur
ces sujets dits régaliens comme on a pu
en juger dans le figaro de lundi dernier
avec l'interview présidentielle
et puis à axel sur lefigaro.fr qui nous
dit pas c'est intéressant parce que ça
ça conforte l'analyse de
la fondation jean jaurès en trente ans
je suis passé de farouches opposants au
clan le pen à me dire qu'il faut qu'elle
passe vu que les autres ne font pas le
travail
il ya un autre point très charbon riga
évoqué brièvement rashed bin a skié leur
la difficulté d'un certain nombre
d'électeurs de gauche a continué à
entrer dans le jeu du front républicain
alors il ya des raisons statistiques qui
veut que les électeurs de gauche sont
moins nombreux est-ce qu'il ya aussi le
fait qu' un certain nombre d'entre eux
peuvent avoir un forme de déception par
rapport à emmanuel macron qui fait
qu'ils se mobiliseraient - dans le cas
d'un second tour c'est certain ils le
disent un bailleur et il l'exprimé en
disant que c est une forme de chantage à
laquelle ils ne céderont pas si
justement ce duel a de nouveau à de
nouveaux lieux maintenant est-ce que ça
suffira pour que marine le pen profite
justement de cet absentéisme c'est pas
sûr encore une fois sans une forme
d'union en misant seulement sur
l'étiquette rassemblement national il ya
quand même peu de chances qu'elle y
arrive et se pose d'ailleurs
régulièrement depuis depuis un certain
nombre d'années
la fameuse fameuse question d'une union
des droites
le fameux plan migrer en fait de 90 ce
qui n'aide pas vraiment de 90,1 déjà
dans les années 70 on se souvient avec
mon nom je n'étais pas né mais le avec
alain de benoist la nouvelle droite le
club de l'horloge
il y avait cette volonté là sauf que
aujourd'hui les ailes jamais marcher ça
n'a jamais fonctionné
et puis on le sait il n'ya jamais de
fusion en réalité et c'est à dire qui a
forcément un parti qui se fait aspirer
ya forcément un courant qui se fait
aspirer et là ce serait
vraisemblablement les lr6 et ce courant
si qui se rapproche du rassemblement
national qui viendrait tout simplement à
disparaître ce serait une forme de
suicide politique donc
donc moi je suis un petit peu plus
réservé sur une victoire possible de
marine le pen ne serait ce que par par
son nom de famille qui a encore une
charge polémique assez assez forte et il
me semble difficile pour elle de le
faire oublier les chars oui je suis sans
doute moins à gauche que vous mais j'ai
du mal à quoi bon ou que tout
sympathisant socialiste et encore plus
un sa passion de la france un soumise il
puisse dire marine le pen emmanuel
macron c'est blanc bonnet et bonnet
blanc et
et partir à la pêche au second tour il
ya un vrai risque vous pensez non mais
je pense qu'en fait il ya enfin le
risque le risque existe pour une raison
qui est que emmanuel macron est détesté
par une partie de cet électorat détester
je pensais que tous on a dit comment
sarkozy on a dit de et alors ce roulante
alors je suis d'accord mais il ya je
pense avec emmanuel macron quelque chose
qui est nouveau à gauche dans le niveau
de détestation du côté notamment de la
france insoumise la chose que révèle par
contre de manière claire le sondage
c'est que dire que il y aurait une
convergence des extrêmes ça ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'il ya une
différence tél politiquement marquées
entre la france insoumise et marine le
pen que en gros cette convergence là ce
qu'explique le sondage c'est que en gros
il n'y crois pas non il ya simplement
l'idée que si une nouvelle fois on
convoque les électeurs de gauche
uniquement à jouer les supplétifs sur
l'idée d'un front républicain ça ne
marchera pas et ça marchera que si
emmanuel macron fait une offre politique
qui donne envie à cet électorat au delà
du barrage d'aller voter pour lui c'est
à dire que il ya vraiment la sensation
que la dernière fois on a voté à gauche
pour emmanuel macron pour faire barrage
et que derrière on a eu non pas une
politique et de gauche et de droite fait
une politique de droite et que en gros
on ne nous y reprendra pas et donc
l'idée c'est de dire ok le barrage mais
le barrage ça ne suffit pas quelle est
l'offre politique à côté
et si c'est simplement agiter
l'épouvantail marine le pen ce truc ne
marchera pas sur certains c'est un filon
qui ne marque plus ça ne marchera que si
à côté et à l'idée de construire une
politique qui répondent à des enjeux sur
lesquels les électeurs de gauche auront
vous avez l'impression que pour
l'instant c'est le cas quand vous lisez
l'interview du chef de l'état au figaro
qui dit la légalisation du cannabis
certainement pas
je pense que la légalisation du cannabis
qui l'attend aujourd'hui de la perdre et
j'ai la sensation qu'on va sortir quand
même d'un moment de crise économique et
sociale que le voilà je pense que le
président la république serait plus
inspiré de dire qu'il met un terme à la
réforme du chômage de l'assurance
chômage qui va largement frapper les
plus pauvres les plus précaires et les
chômeurs et que ça c'est un vrai
discours est un vrai signal qu'il
enverrait à la gauche
après qu'ils veulent pas légaliser le
cannabis je pense que pour une partie de
la population à gauche c'est dommage
mais par contre parce que le débat
pourrait peut-être existé mais par
contre comme marqueur je pense que s'il
veut en prendre
il a les retraites il a l'assurance
chômage il a plein d'autres choses à
envoyer pour en gros dire que derrière
on va voter pour quelqu'un avec non pas
seulement l'assurance qu'on fait un
barrage mais qu'on fait aussi un barrage
pour construire autre chose derrière
et s'il n'y a pas ça plus les trois
points que vous avez envisagé alors je
pense que la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui on se reposera dans six mois
2 est ce que c'est possible que et même
l'idée qu'on se la posent cette question
elle montrera une évolution et bien
voilà le message est passé
je laisse le dernier mot à au pis au
piquet ce lia ou à des dents que ça
c'est un pseudonyme compliqué le
figaro.fr kg dit le rassemblement
national à une politique économique et
sociale de gauche et donc hormis sur
l'immigration ce serait dur de faire une
union des droites et puis ça reste sur
youtube qui considère que marine le pen
ne maîtrise toujours pas les
problématiques relatives à l'économie
c'est une d'effectivement à des points
qu'on avait abordé déjà merci beaucoup à
tous les avoirs de hiatus était
passionnant merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et puis à demain pour un nouveau
point de vue
[Musique]